okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the menstrual cycle the menstrual
cycle is a 28-day cycle which occurs in
women whereby the egg cell is released
and the lining of the uterus kind of
prepares itself for the implantation of
that fertilized egg cell so we're just
going to start with a quick recap here's
the female reproductive system egg cells
are released from these structures here
called the ovaries the egg cell travels
down the oviduct and if it gets
fertilized here in the oviduct it will
implant in the wall of the uterus and
this is where the fetus will grow and
develop another word for the feet the
uterus is the womb so what this diagram
here is showing is it's showing this
lining of the uterus here so we can see
here the uterus lining is quite built up
and here it breaks down so the natural
cycle is kind of controlled by different
hormones the first one at the beginning
of the menstrual cycle at day one we
need to know about it's called FSH that
stands for follicle stimulating hormone
follicle-stimulating hormone and this is
released from the pituitary gland so FSH
it gets released from the pituitary
gland it's a hormone so it travels in
the blood to the ovaries
so what FSH does is it affects here the
ovary
it causes the egg cell to mature so
against that egg cell matured and ready
to be released so that's the role of the
first hormone FSH now FSH it causes a
stimulation of the release of Eastridge
in' the second hormone we need to know
about now estrogen begins with an O that
helps us to remember it's released from
the ovary
so what estrogen does is it allows the
the wall of the uterus to build up kind
of getting ready for the implantation of
a fertilized egg cell so let's have a
look what it does on here so estrogen
it's released from the ovary but what it
does is act here to allow the uterus
lining to build up so the wall gets
thicker here ready for that fertilized
egg cell to come in an implant now what
when estrogen levels get to a certain
level we have the release of our next
hormone this hormone is called LH LH
stands for luteinizing hormone this is
also released for in the pituitary gland
now the way that I remember that these
ones release from the pituitary gland is
the ones that have letters that stand
for them are both released from the
pituitary gland ones which your words
are not so LH is released from the
pituitary glands so on day 14 we have a
sudden surge of LH luteinizing hormone
that causes ovulation so it causes the
release of the egg cell so let's see
that on here so at day 14 LH it actually
acts here so ovulation causing ovulation
which is the release of the egg cell so
the egg cell will start to be released
from the ovary and travel down here
that's on day 14 now the final hormone
that we need to know about it's called
progesterone now progesterone isn't
released from the pituitary gland or the
ovary it's released from this thing
called the corpus luteum so what the
corpus luteum is is one once the once
ovulation has occurred so once the egg
cells been released from the ovary the
follicle develops into this thing called
the corpus luteum so this structure only
exists once ovulation has occurred this
corpus luteum releases progesterone and
that's the next hormone that we need to
know about
so what progesterone does so remember
progesterone it's released from the
corpus luteum progesterone maintains the
lining of the
so it keeps that uterus lighting nice
and thick ready for implantation of a
fertilized egg cell so let's just see
that on the reproductive system
progesterone maintains the uterus lining
so again keeping it nice and thick just
in case that fertilized egg cell comes
down here for implantation okay
so towards the end of the cycle let's
say that implantation has not occurred
what happens is well we'll see in just a
second because we need to know the
effect that progesterone has on the
other hormones because progesterone
actually inhibits the release of LH so
we won't have any further ovulation and
it also inhibits the production of FSH
so when we've got progesterone we're not
going to be producing FSH if there's no
FSH it means we'll have a low lower
level of estrogen as well so when the
progesterone levels start to drop after
a while because the corpus luteum stops
releasing it as progesterone levels go
down it means the uterus lining will no
longer be maintained
this causes the the lining to break down
just like in the first stage of the
cycle so this first stage here remember
this is where as the lining is broken
down this is where bleeding occurs
called menstruation as a part of the
menstrual cycle and then the whole the
whole cycle starts again because if our
progesterone levels go down it means FSH
is no longer inhibited and FSH is
released again so just to summarize the
four hormones involved the FSH East
urgent LH or progesterone FSH and LH are
released from the pituitary gland
estrogen from the ovary progesterone
from the corpus luteum the job of other
sage is to mature the egg cells the
Jordan estrogen is to build up the
lining in the uterus the job of LH is
to allow ovulation to occur the release
of the egg cell and the job of
progesterone is to maintain the levels
of lining in the uterus
finally estrogen is stimulated by FSH LH
is stimulated by estrogen progesterone
is released from the corpus luteum which
only exists once ovulation has occurred
and progesterone inhibits LH and
inhibits FSH as well thank you